well the mayor blames the president for
any and all violence in his state the
mayor himself is actually doing
everything he can to encourage anarchy a
video released last week and shows a man
sucker punching an NYPD officer the guy
in that video he's already back on the
street having been released without bail
other convicts are walking out of
custody with free Christmas goodie bags
from the mayor's office under a new
program in deblasio's New York inmates
released from the care of the city get
gift cards and pre-loaded subway cards
according to the New York Post the city
is even considering giving convicts free
burner cell phones as well
Seth Ferran is an associate editor at
city journal and he joins us listen the
free burner cell phones everybody who
knows anything about criminals knows
that that is actually their preferred
means of communication
why would taxpayers be expected to fund
it well that's a good question
and you know I think it makes some sense
for people who've been released from
prison after 10 or 12 years to get a bus
tickets and spending money these are
people who've just been in jail at
Rikers Island so they don't have that
much to do to get to get back home or
get reintegrated into their communities
but the problem is I'm not sure that
that's really their goal necessarily use
you know these are generally people who
have committed crimes and are you know
bad actors what what this speaks to
though Marc is is a problem in New York
City where we've inverted the priorities
that have kept the city safe for 30
years it used to be that we would focus
on the law-abiding citizens trying to
keep their community safe and prosecute
the bad guys right but now the
priorities are reversed and we seem to
be worrying about the bad guys and
helping them making sure they're not
sitting in jail and leaving the
law-abiding citizen
you know to their tender mercies as well
well it seems to be unwinding a quarter
century of effective policies since
Giuliani came in and introduced the
broken windows theory to New York
leasing and going back really to almost
cliched policies of the 70s and 80s
where the Democrats sympathies well with
the criminal class yes and it started in
the 60s really there's this sense that
the people who are that the people
really need to worry about are the
people who are committing the crimes and
going to jail and that the communities
that they prey upon well that's you know
just a natural state of affairs yeah the
the city became a safe city because we
focused on keeping communities safe
keeping law breakers from doing graffiti
littering yeah you know hanging out
right being drunk
yeah and when we are reversing from
which bigger problems are we heading for
a Baltimore like situation where
effectively the police become so
demoralized by the hostility from City
Hall that they basically say screw this
I'm not gonna take any risks for you
we're not heading in a good direction I
think we would have a long way to go
before we unwound to the point where at
Baltimore New York City's currently
running about 300 homicides a year
Baltimore is about 10th of population
and has many more homicides but things
are looking good
I'd say the pendulum has yet to reach
its climax and it's only at that point
that I think will really reverse things
well we'll keep an eye and see how that
develops thank you for that